ladies and Gentlemen please welcome
Academy governor Kate
amend good evening
everyone on behalf of my fellow
Governors Rory Kennedy and Roger Ross
Williams who is also a nominee
tonight I'd like you w to welcome you to
our Oscar week event celebrating this
year's nominated films in the
documentary short and the documentary
feature categories so thank you for
being here
everyone I'd like to begin by quoting a
couple of
presidents Cheryl Boon
Isaacs our Academy
president said at the recent nominees
luncheon art has no borders art has no
language and it doesn't belong to a
single
Faith Deborah bord the president of the
Los Angeles philarmonic Association
wrote in a recent LA Times article the
Arts breed
compassion and documentary is indeed an
art form that has no borders that breeds
compassion and empathy and insight into
our common
humanity and that's what all the
filmmakers honored here tonight have
succeeded so brilliantly in
doing you all have made some of the most
outstanding films of the year and your
peers have recognized you for that so
we're here to celebrate you and to thank
you for having the vision the courage
and the stamina to do the work that you
do we are all grateful and you are all
winners in our
[Applause]
eyes in the first half of the program
tonight I'll be talking with the do the
filmmakers in the documentary short
category and in the second half Rory
Kennedy will be uh talking with the
feature documentary
nominees so we'll begin with the short
watching these incredible films the word
heroism leapt to my
mind the heroism of risking your life to
rescue drowning refugees from the
sea or digging people out from under
buildings collapsed by air strikes and
bombs the heroism to create a new life
in a foreign country when you are forced
to abandon your
Homeland the heroism to face grav
illness and to make end of life
decisions the heroism to survive the
Holocaust and offer a Lifeline to a new
generation and I think these filmmakers
are heroic too and you're about to see
why so fasten your seat belts and let's
enjoy some moments from this year's
nominated documentry
[Applause]
shorts
extremist directed by Dan
[Music]
Krauss there very few things that you
can be 100% certain
about and you risk hurting people if
you're
wrong my concern is if we continue to
draw it out and we continue to do more
and more things to her were going to
cause more suffering without likely
benefit when I was a young attending I
had been asked to go put a large
catheter in someone's neck she was dying
and I went into life- saving mode right
before we were getting ready I look up
and I see this nurse in the doorway and
she looked at me locking eyes with me
and said call the police they're
torturing a patient in the ICU my heart
dropped into my stomach and I realized
oh my gosh she's right what I'm doing
right now is not going to help her it's
not going to get rid of this disease
that's killing her and I don't want to
do that
anymore living homeless debilitated
failure to thrive he's been
institutionalized for a long time now
we're just keeping a close eye on you to
make sure you're feeling all right do
you have any family members or anybody
that is part of your
family no
well I'm sorry not that no well we'll
help take care of you then if we're
going to treat the treatment is the
matriculas toy so if you guys don't
agree with that and if you say tell me
nope this guy would want everything done
he'd want to live even if he was
vegetative on a ventilator for his life
with a feeding tube then the treatment
is to put them trick in I don't feel
that he is able to make those decisions
and I don't feel that we have someone
who can really make them for him we
don't really know his prognosis we don't
know if he ever had capacity for
decision making so the ethics of this
are murky do you like to make your own
medical decisions or do you like the
doctors to make the decisions for
[Music]
you if we don't get clear we're not
going to give them a chance to opt out
and we're just going to do what we do
with all of our patients which is just
plug them in and let them die on
machines
how would you feel if you were not
getting better on a breathing machine I
don't want to be on a breathing machine
I don't want to suffer okay that machine
I mean know it's his decision but he
know as well as I know I don't want to
see him go you know cuz I haven't lost a
parent yet you know so I wouldn't know
how it feel you know
so we're wondering if maybe this is the
point where we kind of need to stop
decide
and maybe have put the tube in kind of
put you to sleep and have the machine
help breathe for you I didn't make that
choice it's a it's some for some people
it's an easy choice and for some people
it's not I'm 38 I know you're 38 Grandma
I know I don't want to give my life away
yet I
know
4.1 miles directed and produced by
Daphne
[Music]
mataki
foree
yes are
people not
wearing
V there are some five or six people now
into the sea hanging on uh on the rber
boat because the rubber
boat is taking
water
fore
spee
[Music]
speee
no
[Music]
go
go go go go
[Music]
go
what you know fore
[Music]
foree
Joe's violin directed and produced by
kahane cooperman produced by Rafaela
nusen
[Music]
we have very exciting news to share with
you all today today we are receiving a
very special violin there's a man named
Joseph and Joseph is a holocaust
Survivor his hope is that it'll bring a
similar happiness and comfort to a young
life and and we are choosing one student
to play on it during their time here at
Big leag and the student that we have
chosen she really shows a unique ability
to show her emotion through her violin
so we are so excited to announce that
the student that we have chosen is
Briana my name is Ranna Perez I'm 12
years old about to be 13 in a month and
I'm currently in the seventh
grade I've known her since she was in
first grade and it's just been amazing
to see her grow up into a young
[Music]
lady I had a huge Obsession when I was
younger with Tinkerbell and I kind of
still do she's like an independent
hardworking fairy and um she was chosen
for something special and I was chosen
for something special
[Music]
too when she's playing the violin she
she transformed herself totally he's
like she's going inside of the
[Music]
music family is
everything I live with my
mom my my
father he lives like
across town I
guess I didn't notice that she took my
husband and my break so
hard until one day that I saw her crying
and she started playing the violin and
she told me that I believe it's my fault
and I said no it's not your fault it's
not your fault everyone has those days
where it's like dark for them
but most people find their light and my
light is playing the
violin Brianna has been presented with
some
challenges that here in the school
everyone has really assisted her to
[Music]
overcome it's such a joy to teach you
every single day here at school you
display
a
you display a passion for music that is
very rare we know Briana that you will
cherish this violin and enjoy playing on
it just as Joseph
[Applause]
did oh sweetie I'm so proud of you so
happy for you Joseph is going to be very
exciting jph is going to be very EXC you
should
invite always want to meet a survivor of
the we're hoping he can come that would
be really
[Music]
special Shubert's palz for violin and
Orchestra wqxr classical
105.9 time for your morning
[Music]
bu
so I found myself in Siberia in a labor
camp life was very
tough temperature kept dropping just
cold and in
cter they allowed us to write a letter
once a month so I sent the letter to my
mother and I received a
reply
my mother wrote out the lyrics of Sol
song which was very appropriate to her a
mother is missing her
son I I sang it yeah I still remember it
very
[Music]
well
very good e a a b c d e f f e e c a a c
c b b g g
e it's amazing how we were chosen out of
everyone
it looks like a violin
but there's so many secrets and that
violin has so many secrets that nobody
knows watani my homeland directed and
produced by Marcel metalen produced by
Steven Ellis
[Music]
speeech for
spee
speee
to
[Music]
this
byebye
[Music]
spe
fore
[Music]
can
the
fore
[Music]
know
I
[Music]
for
the white helmets directed by Orlando
vadel produced by Joanna
natara
yeah
[Music]
for
suban
[Music]
[Applause]
for
fore
spee
so let's welcome all these filmmakers up
to the
stage
[Applause]
everybody you have your names on
yeah
hi oh wow that's
extraordinary I'd like to start by
having each of you introduce yourself
and which film you're with
and tell us what compelled you to make
this film we'll start with
Dan um I just want to say first of all
thank you for coming tonight and man I I
feel so after watching all those clips I
just I'm so proud to be
shoulder-to-shoulder with all of you um
what an extraordinary group of films
thank you
[Applause]
um so my name is Dan Krauss I directed
extremis um thank
[Applause]
you um your question was what Drew what
compelled me to do the story absolutely
nothing compelled me to do the story at
first um I was um urged to go into the
ICU at the behest of the physician who
you saw featured in that clip she said
you have to come and see what's
happening in this unit you have to hear
the conversations we're having here it's
like nothing you've seen before uh and
she was right but I I really resisted um
the idea of filming in the ICU for for
quite a while um it's a subject I'm not
comfortable with um it's a subject that
scares me and uh I think it scares a lot
of us um and I think you know that's
perhaps one of the reasons that I ended
up pursuing the film um sometimes I
think what we do is move in the
direction of our fear that's our mandate
and um uh working on this film uh was my
way of dealing with the subject that uh
I'm I'm not comfortable addressing in my
own life
Wow you did a great
job def hi everyone H again thank you so
much uh for being here everyone thank
you I'm so uh proud as well and honored
to be among all of you incredible films
next my professor
too
um um yeah incredible films um what what
compelled me um what compelled me was
that um when I was um reading everything
about the refugee crisis that was um
picking last year H and the epicenter of
it was my home country Greece uh I was
here and I felt very kind of removed and
detached from it all still uh and then I
realized that the people who are in the
Forefront uh the front line of it um
were the Greek Coast Guard people who
are very everyday people had a very easy
life H were possibly also detached from
the situation they're not Rescuers
they're not um doctors they're not
volunteers um they used to do a very
easy job and suddenly they're hit uh
with the biggest Refugee crisis and um
it's they have to rescue people who are
not only um have having to flee their
homes because of this terrible War but
then they have to get smuggled and have
to die uh making this terrible Crossing
um when nobody helps them uh with a safe
to provide them with a safe passage and
these um these people who are in the
front lines are for me um complete
modern day heroes uh just because um the
the main character the the captain of
this uh boat I think he just recognizes
that these people only ask for one thing
which is just dignity to live uh and I
think that's very rare in our days
unfortunately um I'm I'm Kahan cooperman
I directed Joe's violin and I'm also
very honored to be amongst these
wonderful filmmakers with these powerful
films and here tonight it's a
unbelievable honor um so I was compelled
to make this film because I've always
been a very strong believer that um
everyone has a story if you just look
below the surface just a little um and I
was actually um compelled by this one
because I I heard a 15-second promo for
the radio station's instrument drive on
driving my car and it mentioned one of
the donations they received which was
the violin of a 91-year-old holocaust
Survivor now I didn't know if that
violin had been purchased recently or
had a story to it but in my mind I
imagined there might be a story and then
I wondered if
this if the student because they were
going to give all the instruments to New
York City school kids in need if the
student would ever know what that story
was and then I wondered what that
child's story was and by the time I sort
of pulled into the parking lot of this
you know quick trip I this idea of two
strangers being connected by a single
musical instrument really compelled me
and the idea of the possibilities of
this gentleman's small act having a
potentially great impact was incredibly
moving to me so once I met with Joseph
and learned about his story and who he
was um decided to follow and see what
would happen with the violin so that's
working
[Applause]
great hi I'm raphaela n house and I
produce Joe's violin and to Echo the
sentiments I feel extremely honored to
be in the company I'm in tonight um well
when Kahani told me about the film
pretty much everything about the story
compelled me personally I'm a first
generation immigrant my grandparents
survived the Holocaust so Joe is
basically like the people I grew up with
and that I miss so much because my
grandparents have passed and my family
came from the Soviet Union in the 70s so
they were just you know immigrants in
America believing in the American Dreams
so the whole Briana story of her as a
Dominican immigrant really compelled me
and the icing on the cake for me is my
mother's a singer and she grew up
singing the songs that her grandparents
taught her and she's recorded them so
the whole idea of Music connecting
generations and you know connecting me
to even like my great-grandparents that
I never met was extremely moving so
Kahani never asked me to produce the
film she just shared her idea for it but
once she told me I really had no choice
I basically told her I'm going to
produce your film and and we were done
so that was it that's
great so my name is Steven Ellis I
produced wani my homeland with Marcel my
colleague and
um I think what compelled me to this
film was something that must have
compelled everyone on this stage we
Marcel met this family in 2013 this very
special family that seemed to embody
what was going on in Syria the this
family that lived on the front line of
this war zone this war zone that was
being destroyed in front of them 2014 a
year later the father of the family was
kidnapped by ISIS and yet again this
family embodied the same story they
continued to do that as they escaped
through to Germany and this story that
was unfolding was this story of great
geopolitical relevance this
great great relevance to what was
happening around us just embodied in
this one family these three little four
little kids who could speak poetically
about their pain and actually felt a
need to make this film and marel would
agree it was beyond compulsion it was a
necessity well um I um yes my my my name
is Marcel Marcel metal and I directed
the film whatson in my homeland and um
as Steven just said uh when I 2013 I met
this family I wanted to do a film about
the serin uprising H Through The Eyes of
children and I was looking for children
and I met this incredible family each of
uh them been full of poetry and this is
basically um the the what you wish if if
you're looking for strong characters but
it was not only this I was able to to
gain a trust of a female Muslim family
of a uh of a world which been basically
totally un
unseen uh throughout uh the entire uh
three years I've been covering Syria and
I was feeling that uh very honored and
very that that I was able to tell the
story and I think they uh realized that
since uh the Islamic State uh or the
upcoming Islamic State there 2013 has
been um hijacking uh basically the
entire Narrative of what's going like
the news coming out of this country and
and basically the entire religion that
they need to open up in order to to have
a counterbalance counter narrative and
uh so it was it it was again appr proof
in order to say what kind of nature this
family was uh to just say we need uh
this part of the story being told and I
it was happy that I I was able to tell
the
story hello um I'm Orlando v idale i
directed The White
helmets thank you um we myself and
Joanna we first came across this we some
friends showed us the the footage you
just saw of um the the baby being
rescued resued this newborn baby being
pulled out of the rubble after a barrel
bomb strike and this footage is
obviously incredibly moving but what we
found um particularly compelling is when
we found out who the rescue workers were
this group of ordinary Syrian civilians
people just like everyone in this room
Bakers tailor Builders um people who had
all decided not to pick up weapons um
not to fight and not to flee Syria and
instead had all decided to stay and
every day go out and risk their lives to
save their fellow citizens and complete
strangers we found that incredibly
moving um and it's also it's a story of
Heroes it's a story of Hope and Syria is
so upsetting this war has been going on
for six years it's so easy to disengage
of it because because we all feel so
helpless but this was a story that that
we believed could resonate it certainly
resonated of us and and that's what Drew
said um I'm Joanna nasar and produced
white helmets and um I think uh it just
to say as well as being honored to be on
this stage what an important year not
just for us as a cohort but also for the
feature dos and for documentary in
general it's it's time that documentary
you know regains its strength so I'm
really pleased to be here with you guys
um I think for just to add to what
orando said we are also compelled as
filmmakers to make stories about
subjects that we feel utterly humbled by
Our Last film we felt very very humbled
by the work of the Rangers and ringa
National Park um and we you know after
we finished making that film we thought
well who else could Inspire us to that
level and and we didn't think anybody
could until we came across the story of
the white helmets and uh and they
managed to at least equal if not beat
that inspiration and I think um I think
it's always important to work you know
for in the service of people that you
feel inspired
[Applause]
by well
Dan
I'm it's kind of shocking to hear you
say that you were just terrified of
facing this because um the film is so
intimate and you feel like you're in the
room with these people um particularly
the families that you followed so tell
you shot it right can you talk a little
bit about how you gained their trust and
how you were able to be in there for
these incredible life or death
moments well you have to
imagine approaching someone on what may
be the worst day of their life and
asking to film it it's really difficult
um I always went in first without a
camera always with the introduction of a
a physician and I just um explained to
them why I thought the film mattered and
um I think for the people who you know
of course many many people declined to
participate the majority the vast
majority uh the the people that did
agree to participate I think saw an
opportunity to connect with others so
they saw the camera not as this
intrusive presence but rather as a
conduit um to not feel
alone um to um help other people who are
facing similar challenges um to take
what would otherwise be pure loss and
transform it
into uh something that can make uh other
people and in their own lives uh
feel comforted and not so
isolated um
you know I think one of the biggest
challenges behind that curtain was
finding the line that divides intimacy
and
intrusiveness and allowing the film to
uh be witnessed to these moments in a
way that
felt like we were being the gift we were
being given the gift of of this
opportunity to witness these decisions
being made without the camera feeling
like it was somehow trampling on the
sacredness of that space um and that
took some figuring out and it took a lot
of uh time with these families sometimes
without the camera to develop a language
and understanding that made everyone
feel
comfortable yeah because you felt the
Dignity of all of them um and that
clearly they trusted you and they felt
comfortable letting you be
there yeah I think um I had some rules
of my own
um that were my sort of foundational
tenants for the filming um to allow
these patients to have the the dignity
that they deserved and that they um
would be remembered with and and um you
know I I Never filmed a patient dying I
Never filmed a patient uh you know being
changed uh being fed through a tube um
these were things that didn't help me um
advance theage M of the story and so
dignity was always the kind of Hallmark
rule for filming um these patients gave
a lot of it and I wanted to respect
[Applause]
it
Daphne well you're the captain is just
incredible and like you said their
ordinary people these Coast Guard um
captains and
um how did you convince them to let you
go out on the ship with them and to
film um it probably took a while it took
a it took a very long time um when when
I realized um that I wanted to tell this
story um through his eyes and I wanted
to be on this Coast Guard boat because
it was so important to be there because
uh it was there when these two worlds
were are actually colliding uh the world
of our comfort zone and this other
reality that is uh still a reality um I
contacted everyone that I knew in the
Greek Ministry of
uh Mar time and uh they wouldn't let me
to go on this boat uh because they don't
let any filmmakers and any journalists
to go on the boat because it's unsafe um
uh but I really convinced them I he
persisted and I convinced them that it
was very important to tell this story
from that boat and through his eyes um
and I hadn't spoken to this the captain
uh until I was on the airport uh about
to fly to Greece I finally reached him
on the phone and I and I said to him um
um are there any boats Crossing what is
the situation and he said to me um just
just come here and see with your own
eyes I really don't have any world words
to explain to you the situation so in
his voice I really understood uh the
weight of the situation I really
understood how um how much uh uh he's
caring uh how much this responsibility
uh that he has means and the
psychological uh effect that it has on
him so I realized that he was he
immediately that he was the one that I
would tell this story uh through and
when I met him in person as soon as I
arrived on the island he was a man that
um he had nothing to hide um he led me
into his life and trusted me completely
and I think that trust is something very
important uh for uh documentary film
making and journalism um he realized
that I wanted to tell a a truthful
uh story of what exactly is going on
with no sensationalization or anything
just tell what's happening and because
he feels so alone there because there is
no help um he's been carrying him and
three other colleagues and their four
member Crews have been carrying the
weight of this entire Refugee crisis um
in the middle of the the water of a
peaceful country Greece uh which is also
bankrupt and has no means to support
this um he like I feel the rest of the
people that were being rescued the rest
of the people on the island they and
there is somebody on the film saying
that they needed they need the world to
see it so he completely led me into his
life because of
that
GL well there there's a moment where um
is he the one that tells you to put the
camera down
yeah um that's interesting I opened the
film I decided to open the film with
this scene um when
um the captain brings up a baby and he
tells me put the camera down hold the
baby and I open the SE the film with
this scene because before I went there I
had this huge ethical dilemma uh about
what my role is of as a filmmaker what
would I do if I see people drowning and
you know would I put the camera down and
jump in the water and rescue them what
would I do and I decided that my role is
that I'm a filmmaker and I needed to
just tell this story The Way It Is in
the most accurate uh way and honest way
and give Justice to the people um but
being on the boat the situation was
entirely different uh like I mentioned
before these people um are not even
trained to do this they are not trained
to do CPR they were just their job was
to do routine border patrol and they're
just caught in the middle of this so
they're just as shocked as I am and
everyone on this tiny Bo is completely
shocked so and the situation is frantic
and chaotic and everyone including me
are in the in the middle of this just
fine line between life and death and at
this moment when he tells me put the
camera down and hold this baby I
honestly couldn't care less about making
a film so I did what he told
me
that's so Connie um I read that there
were 3,000 instruments donated in this
this instrument Drive um but you heard
about Joseph initially so how did he
respond to so when I first heard about
it was the it was the promo it mentioned
two um donations a flute from Brooklyn
and a violin from the Upper West Side um
which I thought was a trombone when I
wrote to the radio station but I was
corrected um and um so I I had to First
earn the trust of the people at the
radio station they felt like you know
this gentleman had donated his violin
and they didn't want to for obvious
reasons just give his contact
information away so I I you know worked
to gain their trust and tell them where
I was coming from that I thought there
was something potentially beautiful in
the idea of two strangers who live in
the same city who don't know each other
that are going to be connected by this
violin I did not know yet where the
violin what school it was going to go to
or what young girl it was going to go to
but I thought it based on you know what
I imagined the story might be that it
could be worth it so uh Jo they
contacted Joseph and um he couldn't for
the life of him understand why anyone
would be interested in him at all um but
still let me come and I knocked on his
door and I spent about an hour with him
so I learned indeed there was a very
extremely poignant story attached to
this
violin and also that at 91 um that he
was G to be able to tell it in his own
words um so I let I left you know that
hour meeting in his apartment knowing
that I I wasn't sure what would happen
but I wanted to find out so I started to
follow follow it and it ended up really
um you know these two people who are
born 80 years apart completely different
cultural backgrounds um both use music
to get through hardships um you know the
hardship in the film that we show Briana
facing
um is the surface of what she deals with
in life we needed to respect her privacy
um but it's an indication of some of the
darker things in her life um and so even
though the darkness that Joseph
experienced during World War II and the
Darkness that she has faced as a young
girl growing up in the poorest
congressional district in the country
are very different they both use music
to and the violin specifically to get
them through things to channel their
emotions and I felt like there was
something in so powerful in that Bond
and the fact that when they did
meet which was another I didn't know if
they would connect but they connected in
such a deep way she's very unusual
12-year-old girl who understood
intrinsically the intangible value of
this piece of wood
yeah yeah so it was really remarkable
and very moving and they're
still they they love each other and
they're still in touch and it's just a
really amazing thing and so he you know
she he gave the gift of the violin but
really he he got this Incredible Gift
back that this he's now um almost 94 and
in the the last couple years of his life
have been unbelievably exciting he's so
excited he still doesn't understand why
anyone's in interested but but he's so
moved and loves Briana and Banna loves
him and you know she understands the
history of it and you know yeah this the
scene where they meet is just wonderful
yeah thank you yeah it was very moving
at the time I bet bet it was well Briana
was
[Applause]
yeah you brought bana here um for the
Nom's luncheon is she going to come to
the oh she's coming oh good I I have to
say after the nominee luncheon she flew
back to New York and the next day went
back to being a grade n student so we're
we have no idea how she's processing any
of this but she's extremely excited and
she's going to be flying out on Saturday
and her mom is coming which she was the
most excited about the M her mom that's
in the movie that's fantastic and her
teacher yeah
because yeah I mean she really did
sense the importance of this of this
gift and she you you got that feeling
from her that no incredibly I mean as
Kahani alluded to like we've never met
such a poised 12-year-old girl that was
just so deep and profound and we we'd
often joke that if we'd written this as
a fiction film nobody would have
believed it everybody would have said no
she can't say that kids don't say that
but she really did and um she no she's
all heart and she like as Connie was
saying like their relationship their pen
pals And when they see each other like
they're holding each other the whole
time at screenings and like it's a very
deep deep relationship for both of them
and how they
connected that's wonderful yeah and I
think I think for Joseph it's also
exciting because you know he is he's
turning 94 next month and he did what he
thought was a really simple thing he
just gave away an instrument he doesn't
use it and nowhere in his Wildest Dreams
did he imagine it would go to somebody
like Briana and you know what would
ensue from that so
[Applause]
yeah okay so
um
Marcel you you've been to um Syria quite
a bit I
understand do you want to tell us a
little bit more
about how you were able to travel there
so much and and I know that something
that's missing from the clip that we saw
is the father um yeah um so I I I
started actually um 2011 to uh cover
suria as a still photographer so I I'm
uh pretty uh new into film making it was
suria who um was the reason why I first
started to do a video because uh it was
the only way way to get into the country
uh to get a Visa as a doctor and not as
a forge exactly I had double name my
mother's South American so I I applied
uh with my first name which nobody knows
that I'm a still photographer since 15
years been covering a lot of conflict uh
and uh I could use my first name uh
metal which uh you could Google it up
but you would never find me Marcel
metal the the photographer so H and I uh
was in medical school so I was the uh
doctor metal who applied for a student
visa to study Arabic H and so I was not
able to take my my big camera my photo
camera uh and I instead would take
pictures with my iPhone for Spiegel and
uh the first time I took a normal
camcorder and it this was the reason why
that I could the first year 2011 to
understand what it means that if how
does a movement is created how this
clandestine World works and um and this
was actually the the the most important
reason why I was able still 2013 to go
inside the country because I would been
traveling so many times in an hour that
I had a huge network of people on the
ground who would help me uh to to go in
and and to go out again safely and uh in
2013 um when I decided to do the film uh
Through The Eyes of children uh I had
known the father of this wonderful
children from previous trips and I uh I
met him again and asked him that I need
children he said the only children who
are in this part of alipo in this front
line which I thought it's it's visual
interesting H I would like to find
children there said with my own children
and then I started following them the
children are
extraordinary I think yeah the the the
children are extraordinary and I think
uh what by following them and Stephen
and me uh been able to to to kind of
tell the story of over three years so it
was 2013 and I think the last uh bit of
uh video we we shot was uh in
201 15 16 16 actually 16 in in April so
you you you you meet the family in in
Aleppo you get to know them uh and you
understand why they have to leave and
you understand by how they arrived to
Germany and the inability of the
children who are very easy to adapt into
their new environment that and the
mother is trapped still in her uh in her
past uh emotionally trapped uh and you
understand the most important part which
for me being German uh I thought is the
message I want to get out there uh
that if she would have been able to
choose she never would have left and uh
I think you can see by the way of how
she's been Mourning and that's why the
film name Waton which is uh my homeland
the the desperate kind of mourning for
Homeland they lost H I wanted to get
this message out that people are not
coming to abuse our welfare system uh
just they're not able to survive in
their own country yeah
but when when they the the young Bo says
forgive us Syria just so Stephen do you
want want to talk about
editing well I think you know one of the
things that's hard about a film like
this is when do you stop you know you
could we could still be making this film
we could still be making this film in 10
years time and um I hope we won't still
be making films like this in 10 years
time and I hope that the world settles
down around us actually but um I think
one of the one of the things that we
tried to do was make a film that was
very much about psychological change
that everything was about the
psychological change in these children
and in the mother and if
it if if the if any aspect of it
diverged from that then it kind of
wasn't necessary in the film The process
and the context sat away from all of
that it was all just about what these
kids perceived and in that way we wanted
to make a film that really showed the
pure innocence of these kids of people
going through an absolute crisis
unbiased by the religion or politics of
the
environment
and we struggled to make this film
really tried to finish it in
2014 again in 2015 again in 2016 tried
to find this this kind of end point and
then the eldest daughter who was at this
stage kind of becoming you know a little
bit of a German teenager was being a bit
resistant to filming and Marcel showed
some of the footage from of of the
father from the very beginning of the
film where he talks about the sacrifice
that he's
making to keep them on the front line
and um she reflects on that and she
gives the line that actually currently
finishes the film she says now I
understand the sacrifice that my dad
made now I understand the sacrifices
that my mom made I understand the
meaning of of Homeland and at that point
we kind of knew that we had at least one
close you know at least one end to a
film so well you told their story
beautifully thank
you now the white helmet you're speaking
of children and in a war zone um you're
saying saying that it originated by
seeing the the footage um of the baby
being rescued so did you um go to Syria
and and then work with these there's
there's thousands of these the white
helment rescue people right there's
there's 3,000 of them yeah yeah um no no
we didn't go to Syria we we've actually
it's funny a a lot of our careers we
spent making films in in conflict zones
but in this case we shot this film at
the beginning of last year and at that
point about up for about nine months
before that there had been virtually no
Western journalists in eastern Aleppo
because we we've all tragically seen
what happened to to most of them um and
they ended up being kidnapped so we
realized at the beginning that we
couldn't go and film there and instead
we we had a real opportunity to
collaborate with the white helmets
themselves they film a lot of their
rescues because they want the world to
see what's going on on the ground inside
Syria so they wear GoPro cameras and and
use small video cameras and we worked
very closely with a young white helmet
called Haled ctib who began documenting
the the crisis in Syria at the age of 16
and he began doing that on his mobile
phone and gradually got better and
became an accomplished photographer he's
had his work in the New York Times um
and Haled so what we did is we filmed
for five weeks on the border with about
30 white white helmets and Haled joined
those white helmets and he spent that
time working very closely with our
Director of Photography Franklin da um
and haled's an incredibly fast learner
and the the small contribution that that
we could make as a film team was to help
improve his documentary storytelling
techniques um and then at the end of
those five weeks when the white helmets
went back into into Syria into into
Aleppo howed continued to do his normal
job of documenting their rescues except
he shared the material of us and that's
what makes up the film is is what we
shot on the border and what howed shot
inside
Syria well Joanna I know that you use
film for social impact and Outreach and
have you um shown this this
film yeah um yeah I mean we we actually
made this film as a short partly because
the issue was just so urgent so we had
you know a fairly heated discussion
actually at the beginning where we
debated whether this would be a feature
Dock and certainly the material was was
definitely there um but and this doesn't
normally happen with producer and
director but it was actually Orlando who
said no it it has to be a short because
we have to do it quickly we can't you
know we can't we can't take that time
these people need their story told and
to as many people as possible as quickly
as possible um you know luckily we we
showed we we distributed the film with
Netflix so that meant 190 countries 21
languages there's no other way to see
that film that quickly and it is an
urgent story so we feel like that was
exactly the right move to make the film
within one year and then you know and
then the film has been shown in various
parliaments and shared around taste
makers and decision makers high-profile
people the white helmets were actually
nominated for a Nobel Peace Prize last
year and so yeah I mean these people are
incredible
yeah yeah I mean there there's a figure
at the end of the film that you see that
I think in the film is 58,000 lives that
they've saved which is already huge and
now that figure is
82,000
yeah well thank
you thank all of you for your courage
your compassion and your Artistry these
films are all Extraordinary and I think
they've changed your lives they've
probably changed the lives of the people
in them and they're having the same
effect on all of us so thank Youk you
thank
you and
now stay stay in your seats because Rory
will be introducing the doc the uh
feature doc filmmakers thank you
please welcome Academy Governor Rory
[Applause]
Kennedy is this working there we go um
those were really incredible films thank
you all again to all the shorts really
amazing work and I want to take a moment
and just thank the academy I um think we
would all agree that that our voting
process is working with all the amazing
films so I want to thank all of the
members for watching these films for
voting on them on in record numbers and
I think that we would all agree that at
least our Democratic process here at the
Academy is working very very
well
um um but I do I do want to say that
that given everything that is going on
in the in our country today I am so
proud to be a documentary filmmaker and
I just love each and every one of these
films that has been nominated here and
I'm so proud to have any vague
association with them just as being a
fellow documentary filmmaker um you know
these I'm going to focus on the features
now but these films help us have such a
deeper understanding of race in America
of what it means to be a refugee fleeing
your country because of poverty and War
and Desperation what it means to grow up
as an autistic
child people don't read so much anymore
these days and they don't and it's a
shame but they do watch films and they
do watch
documentaries and documentaries really
are providing people an outlet and one
of the few places where they're getting
in-depth knowledge about any particular
issue democracy only works when we have
an informed electorate and an informed
public so in my
mind
documentaries play a really critical
role right now and for for the for the
uh next well four years but
um I think these stories that you're
telling and that you're sharing with us
are helping to bridge a divide they can
um and we are in a in a divided nation
and they help connect us to our fellow
citizens um they ground us all in a
common experience in watching these
films an experience that transcends
politics and any acts of other
Rising when we watch these films we feel
and we feel not because we're told to
feel but simply because we can't help
ourselves because these films are so
good so I want to thank all of the
filmmakers I want to thank you for your
commitment for your extraordinary talent
and for your work and for giving us
these these gifts you are fighting the
good fight which is all we can do
because in the end we are all in this
together so I'm now I have the great
honor of introducing you to the clips of
the feature films and looking forward to
our discussion after watching those
thank you all very
[Applause]
much fire at Sea directed and produced
by John Franco Roi produced by Donatella
poo
fore
[Music]
spe
for
no a
[Music]
foree
for
fore
br
[Music]
for
fore
foree
spee
[Music]
for
space I am not your negro directed and
produced by Raul peek produced by Ry
gretti produced by AAR
peek the church was packed in the Pew
before me sat Marlon Brando Sammy Davis
ear kit Sydney P
nearby I saw Harry bante sitting next to
ketta
King I have a childhood Handover thing
about not weeping in public and I was
concentrating on holding myself
together I did not want to weep for
Martin tears seemed
futile but I may also have been afraid
and I could not have been the only one
that if I began to
weep I would not be able to
stop I started to cry and I
stumbled Sammy grabbed my
arm the story of the Negro in America is
the story of
America it is not a pretty
[Music]
[Applause]
story were you able to listen to the
show backstage good deal of it but then
I was behind the r here yes so I heard
only some of it did you hear anything
that you disagreed with or I disagreed
with a great deal of it and of course
it's a good deal I agree with but I
think uh he is overlooking one very
important matter I think each one of us
I think is terribly alone he lives his
own individual life he has all kinds of
obstacles in the way of religion or
color or size or shape or lack of
ability and the problem is to become a
man but what I was discussing was not
that problem really I was discussing the
difficulties the obstacles the very the
very real danger of death thrown up by
the society when a negro when a black
man attempts to become a man all this
emphasis upon black man and white does
emphasize something which is here but it
emphasize it or perhaps exaggerates it
and therefore makes us for put people
together in groups which they ought not
to be in I have more in common with a
black scholar than I have with a white
man who's against scholarship and you
have more in common with a white author
than you have with someone who's against
all literature so why must we always
concentrate on color or religion or this
they're are other ways of connecting men
I'll tell you this when I left this
country in 1948 I left this country for
one reason only one reason I didn't care
where I went I might have gone to Hong
Kong I might have gone to timbuk to I
ended up in Paris on the streets of
Paris with $40 in my pocket on the
theory that nothing worse could happen
to me there that it already happened to
me here you talk about making it as a
writer by yourself you had to be able
then to turn up all the antenna with
which you live because once you turn
your back on this Society you may die
you may die and it's very hard to
consider a typewriter and concentrate on
that if you're afraid of the world
around you the years I lived in Paris
did one thing for me they released me
from that particular social Terror which
was not the paranoia of my own mind but
a real social danger visible in the face
of every cop every
boss
[Applause]
everybody I don't know what most white
people in this country feel but I can
only include what they feel from the
state of their institutions I don't know
if white Christians hate Negroes or not
but I know that we have a Christian
Church which is white and a Christian
Church which is which is black I know as
Malcolm X once put it the most
segregated hour in American life is high
noon on Sunday that says a great deal
for me about a Christian Nation it means
that I can't afford to trust most white
Christians and certainly cannot trust
the Christian church I don't know
whether the labor unions and their
bosses really hate me that doesn't
matter but I know I'm not in their
unions I don't know if the real estate
Lobby is anything against black people
but I know the real estate lobbies Keep
Me In the Ghetto I don't know if the
Board of Education hates black people
but I know the textbooks that give my
children to read and the schools that we
have to go to now this is the evidence
you want me to make an Act of Faith
risking myself my wife my woman my sist
my children on some idealism which you
assure me exists in America which I have
never
[Applause]
seen
life animated directed and produced by
Roger was Willams produced by Julie
Goldman Owen has said almost nothing but
gibberish since
then we're beginning to give up
hope so on Walt's 9th birthday he's in
the backyard with his
buddies party ends the kids leave
and Walt gets a little leapy a little
emotional and then Owen follows us into
the kitchen looking expectant like he's
looking at the two of us he stands there
stock still like something's bubbling
up and he says Walter doesn't want to
grow up like mowgly or Peter Pan and off
he runs I was like what the hell just
happened did Owen just say Walter
doesn't want to grow like Peter Pan or
mowley Peter Pan doesn't want to grow up
cuz he wants to stay a boy and be a
Neverland once you're grown up you can
never come back never I felt the same
way that Walter felt when he was nine a
teeny tiny
bits when you grow up you lose all your
magical Enchanted childhood
times this wasn't just a sentence this
was a complex sentence of a complex Lex
thought of something that we didn't even
see and all of a sudden it became clear
to us he's using these movies to make
sense of the world he actually is living
in our world but I said to Ron you know
we've got to try and figure out if we
can have him talk to us at
all so I go up to his room I see Owen on
the bed flipping through a Disney
book and I see sort of over to my left I
see Yago the puppet now Yago is the evil
sidekick to the villain Jafar from
Aladdin now I know Owen loves his puppet
Jafar Jafar
get I grabbed the puppet I pull it up to
my elbow and I begin to crawl across the
rug as quietly as I can and Owen turns
to the puppet like he's bumping into an
old friend
I say to him Owen Owen how does it feel
to be
you and I said not good cuz I don't have
any
friends now I'm under the bed
spread and I just bite down
hard you
know I just say to myself stay in
character and I said okay okay Owen when
did you and I become such good
friends and he said when I watched
Aladdin you made me
laugh and then we talk uh Owen and
Yago for a minute minute and a
half it's the first conversation we've
ever
had and then all of a sudden I hear him
say I love the way your F little mind
works
that's the next line of dialogue that's
Jafar the villain to his evil sidekick
Yago I love the way all foul little mind
works and then I run down and grab
Cornelia I'm like he's memorized all the
movies I mean he's memorized them all if
you throw him a line of dialogue he'll
throw you back the next line and at that
point it was like a a window opened like
a light went
on and we began to speak to him in
Disney dialogue the whole
[Music]
family I memorized every Disney animated
movie ever
made I memorized the credits and that's
how I taught myself to read felt like a
great
wonderful world of Enchantment when we'd
be down in the basement watching movies
when it would kind of all come together
where you know
that's when we drew own
[Music]
out and these were handdrawn figures
with
exaggerated expression exaggerated
emotion it was easier for him to
interpret all of
this I think the idea that it never
changes and everything else is changing
constantly every other part of his life
our lives as his parents we're getting
older you know Walter's getting older
you know people are dying everything's
changing and that's the one thing that
he can hang on to that never
changes OJ made in America directed and
produced by Ezra Edelman produced by
Caroline
waterlow you think that there members of
the jury that voted to acquit OJ because
of Rodney King yes you do yes how many
of you think felt that way oh probably
90% of
was
90% did you feel that way
yes that was pidb M you think that's
right the majority of the world or the
majority of Americans think that we're
group of idiots uh who didn't get it
right I think that the jury was made to
be the scapegoat for their
faults it was a mistake to present firm
in the way they did it was a mistake to
let Darden get up there and be a part of
that case had they come correct had they
had the right attorneys up there putting
on the case that they need to put on
they would have won it wasn't
payback they messed
up it may have been payback but it
wasn't payback for anything that
happened recently it was payback for
what's happened over the last 400
years it was payback for how black
people are treated in
[Music]
America I believe that that was on the
minds of every black person in America
in the matter of the people of the State
of California versus forthal James
Simpson case number ba 097
we the jury and the above entitled
action find the defendant orw oral James
Simpson not
guilty
[Music]
there there there was
Joy you you could hear it in the barers
shop or the beauty salon or the
classroom at the school or on the
[Music]
streets a release of
breath
exhaling ah the juice is loose he's Lo
he's Lo free at last free at last thank
God Almighty I'm free at
[Music]
last it was like that day Jackie
Robertson opened the door for black
[Music]
players this trial tapped into the
racial history of Los Angeles I didn't
realize how much it tapped into the
national
pain of race
[Music]
relations it was all so much bigger than
we were so much
[Music]
bigger
I think the black Jubilation was very
offensive and very
hurtful you laugh that know did itman
did it the races of
America those films of African-Americans
cheering and whites crying it put a huge
red line across
Society
[Music]
certainly the resentment that
African-Americans have towards
whites was
shocking it was absolutely
[Music]
shocking now you know how it
feels 13th directed and produced by Ava
duer produced by Spencer aick produced
by Howard
Baris we are now in an era where
Democrats and Republicans alike have
decided that it's not in their interest
anymore to maintain uh the prison system
as it is now all of a sudden Hillary
Clinton is meeting with black lives
matter activists and talking about it
it's time to change our approach and end
the era of mass incarceration
she's made a major address on it we will
reform our criminal justice system from
end to end and rebuild trust between law
enforcement and the communities they
serve President Obama going in prison
you know as the first sitting president
to ever visit a prison we've got an
opportunity to make a difference at a
time when overall violent crime rates
have been dropping at the same time as
incarcerations last year dropped for the
first time in 40 years and conservatives
who were always seen or understood
within the narrative as being the tough
on crime ones um have now uh embraced
Justice Reform it's very uh man bites
dog you see Texas used to spend billions
locking people up for minor offenses we
shifted our Focus to diversionary
programs like Community Supervision uh
we got to ask ourselves do we feel
comfortable uh with people taking the
lead of a conversation in a moment where
it feels right politically historically
when one looks at efforts to create
reforms they
inevitably lead to more repression and
so if we leave it up to them what
they're going to do is they're going to
Tinker with the system they're not going
to do the sort of change that we need to
see as a country to get us out of this
mess and they're certainly not going to
go backwards and fix the mess that
they've made because they're not ready
to make that admission but as a country
I don't think we've ever been ready to
make the admission that that we have
steamrolled through entire communities
and multiple Generations when you think
about things like slavery and Jim Crow
and all the other systems of Oppression
that have led us to where we are
today so much fun I love it I love it we
having a good
time USA
[Applause]
USA
knock the crap out of him would you
seriously get him get him out of
[Music]
here in the good old days this doesn't
happen because they used to treat them
very very rough and when they protested
once you know they would not do it again
so easily like to punch him in the
face
I love the old days you know what they
used to do to guys like that when they
were in a place like
this they'd be carried out on a
stretcher
[Music]
folks true knocking the hell out of that
big mouth the next time we see him we
might have to kill him in the good old
days they'd rip him out of that seat so
fast shut up the shut the hell
no I would
why here
[Music]
out in the good old
days law enforcement acted a lot quicker
than
this a lot
quicker and we're going to enforce the
law and American should remember that if
we're going to have
law I I Am the Law and Order
[Applause]
candidate we thought I mean they called
the end of slavery Jubilee we thought we
were done then and then you had 100
Years of Jim Crow Terror and
lynching Dr King these guys come on the
scene Ella Joe Baker fan L hyr we get
the bills passed to vote and then they
break out the handcuffs label you felon
you can't vote or get a job so we don't
know what the next iteration of this
will be but it will be it will be and we
will have to be
[Applause]
vigilant I would like to ask the
filmmakers of these extraordinary films
to come up and join us for a discussion
please thank you
good how you doing nice to meet
you I think I think you're over
yeah wow huh how incredible were those
films
really
[Applause]
amazing really
amazing so um there's so many amazing
people on this panel and we don't have a
lot of time so um I want to try to talk
to all of you and I want to talk to all
of you for hours and hours but
unfortunately we we are tight on time so
I'm going to ask if you could all just
introduce yourselves and what your role
was on the film and the film you worked
on and produced or directed and also if
there are any characters from your film
in the audience that you would like to
recognize who are here we would love to
acknowledge their enormous role in the
films that you made as well so would you
like to start yes good evening my name
is JN fosi I'm a director and producer
of
faty and
uh thank you for the opportunity because
we have here Dr Baro who just arrived
today from Meda
so thank you P was a long trip I guess
he's still like he would like to be
sleeping now
but and
uh
doesn't speak English so I I say she's
the producer of the
F she's very shy because she's very
sorry she doesn't speak a word of
English she's very moved to be here in
this moment with all these people here
on the
stage
because they all believe
that because they all believe that
documentary and film and Cinema can
still change the world and we are all
sitting here with this belief so thank
you so much for being with
[Applause]
you and this is
beautiful
and The Sensation to be on the same side
with people so wonderful
incredible it makes it World less cold
and less ugly but more
beautiful well it's very hard to follow
you imagine me she was my
producer uh my name name is a AEK and
I'm a producer on I'm not your
negro uh I'm Ral peek and I'm uh
producer director of I'm not
[Applause]
jigo and I amti and I'm the producer of
I am na negro and I'm especially proud
to be here tonight with such filmmakers
thank thank
[Applause]
you hi um I'm Roger Ross Williams I'm
the director of Life animated and it's
it's so incredible because um I'm so
proud of my community because we have
really sort of um as a community by um
nominating these films that are so
important all of them um and
representing the experience um of the
African-American experience and and the
story of of African-Americans and it's
really um I think that we've uh We've
sort of set a new set the bar for the
Academy from from the documentary
standpoint so congratulations to you
all here
here I am Julie Goldman I'm the producer
of Life animated and I'd like to
introduce cornelus seskin who is
[Applause]
here
hi I'm Ezra Edelman the producer and
director of OJ made in
America I'm Caroline waterlow I produced
OJ made in America with Ezra and it's a
huge honor to be here thank
you my name is Spencer avick I'm the
producer and editor of
13th
my name is Howard beish I'm the producer
on 13th and I just want to mention who's
not here in person but who's here in
spirit because she's in New Zealand
shooting her next film is Ava
duver okay thank you all um and thank
you again for being here so I want to
get right into it so one Franco talk to
me about your film my understand
understanding is that you went to the
island of lampedusa for a long period of
time a good amount of time before you
even started filming that documentary
can you tell me why you decided to go
there without filming first why that was
important to
you well for me it's always important to
be in a in a place first and trying to
understand when I went to lampedusa I
did know much about lampedusa as much um
you know people talked with through the
to the news paper the media and it was
this island which most of the time is
not even represented in a map you know
it's like out of the maps in Italy it's
very close to Africa and we all heard
that lampedusa is the beacon is the
place first place where people arrive
from Africa and for years lampedusa was
always on the front line but you know
most of the time also the media portray
lampedusa just related to the phenomen
of the migration and the good and the
bad sometime with tragedies but now
nobody really ever show that this also
an island with people living there so
for me it was also important to to
change the point of view and tell me
also the story of the people of the
island like Dr Baro that he's the first
person I met when I was there and
somehow drove me into this film so for
me it was important to know the people
and to see what was the um the identity
of this place and what was the story of
this island through the people passing
by the island and to the people living
into the island so it took me one and a
half year to be there from the begin
beginning the first three months I was
there without a camera trying to see if
I was able to make this film and then
slowly slowly I became engaged and
devoted to to the story that I was going
to say and especially meeting the people
that are in the film Samuel
Zaria all the people that are in the
part and this enormous um constant mass
of people that they passed through
lampedusa and to see also the
relationship with this island and the
people passing by which it changed
through the years because because when I
started the film also there was like the
border of lampedusa was moved into the
middle of the sea so the migrants didn't
arrive anymore directly to lampedusa but
they been the rescue saved in the middle
of the water and then brought into
lampedusa so also this little island
somehow is living a a separation between
these two groups and Dr bolo is somehow
the link in between the people of the
island and the migrant so it was a very
complex structure and really very strong
experience for me to be there and be
able in this one and a half year to tell
the story both of the people of the
island and people arriving this island
reaching for freedom and most of the
time dying into the sea because we don't
have we have to remember that more than
27,000 people die in this last 15 years
crossing the water from Africa to
lampedusa and more than 500,000 people
pass by from this island which always
open itself to the migrants so I thought
this island become somehow the metaphor
of this transversal phenomena of the
migration R in the world so how did you
handle dealing with so many people who
who died during the course of your time
there um I imagine that was very
difficult well I saw death many in times
when I was in lampedusa but I never
wanted really to to film that the
tragedy except there's a moment in the
film which the whole film somehow was
build to arrive to that moment where we
see that because I really literally
encountered death in the middle of the
sea I was for more than 40 days in this
Navy doing rescue in the middle of the
sea and we did many operation there and
they did many operation I was there
witnessing and somehow sharing the all
the daily experience there and one day
death really literally came to me and I
was filming I didn't know we encountered
this boat completely lost in the middle
of Mediterranean Sea there were like
more than 300 people on this boat and at
the beginning it looked like it was like
a regular rescue like every every day
sometime more than 2,000 people are
rescuing to the sea or sometime even 5
6,000 in the weekend so it was one of
the regular approach and suddenly I see
this body coming on my feet and I had a
split of the of the second to theci side
do I want to tell this story do I want
to show this and then I did it and uh I
also forced myself to go under this boat
where we discovered there were more than
50 people die like in a CH gas like
during the second world world these
people die fumed by the gases of put as
Dr B was describing very well they're
forced under the boat and most of the
time people you know without they they
breathe the the fume of the engine and
uh they find death in a desperately and
horrible condition so I thought it's
unacceptable that nowadays people find
death in this way and um and that's what
the film is is a cry of help and say
it's unacceptable people die try to
reach freedom and try to cross the the
the the sea well I um so appreciated
your film and you know I we've all been
exposed to this it's you know the the
greatest humanitarian crisis of our time
and I so appreciate your approach to it
and humanizing it and reminding us
everything that's going on over there
and and and what's at stake at the end
of the day which is these these human
lives so thank you for telling the story
thank you so much thank
you um so we're uh I am not your negro
rul I would love to hear from you uh my
understanding is you grew up in Haiti is
that correct uh well I grew up in a lot
of places yes um Haiti I was born in
Haiti and went to Congo when I was eight
and then to the United States France
Germany so how were you first exposed to
James
Baldwin um very early on uh I was still
a you
know uh not a teenager anymore but I was
1718 uh on my way between finishing high
school and going to University to
college and um you know people have been
asking me that question and I try to
find out how I know who gave me the
first Baldwin book and I think I'm not
sure but I think it was a a black
American gay couple that I met in Berlin
my first year in Berlin and we were
always having those discussion about
racism and and in America especially and
the type of anger that I felt they had
all the time when the subject came up
and and coming from Haiti where we have
a different type of identity it toward
racism um probably through thanks to our
history um so I was telling them you
know I I could not live being angry like
this every day and and then they gave me
uh the fire next time which was my first
Baldwin book and and of course it
changed my life and and my way of seeing
uh these
problems you interweave you take these
these writings that were many decades
ago and part of your approach is to
interweave them with more current Day
events many of which hadn't happened I
imagine by the time you had started
filming so did the events happen and
then you decided to bring it up to the
current day or did you anticipate that
events would happen and that that was
always the idea going into the making of
This film well this film was really a
particular film for me to make because
it was like the concept was already
there or the words were already there
because those are the words I grew up
with and about 10 years ago I felt that
we were in a place uh by the way not
only here in the United States but
elsewhere in Europe as well uh and we
had all Trump in Italy through
biscone uh that's exactly the same
typical type of
authoritarian uh uh
Behavior Uh and I felt like we were
sinking in you know in sort of ignorance
of General ignorance and the media was
not really doing its job properly and
and I felt like it was time you know to
bring back those words those incredible
Baldwin words and
Analysis uh and the film was for me you
know how do I bring it in a cinematic
form for the big screen uh so that the
younger generation could again have
access access to it and and have the
same impact it had on me so it was
really how do I construct that project
much more than you know go and shoot and
and try to find your characters and you
know to build the film it it was really
starting with the
words well it's beautifully done it's
really it's really a it's really a
poetry you know it's so I'd like to open
up to to your team I and Remy as as well
um we're here in Hollywood and um we've
struggled here at the Academy with race
issues um and and I know Baldwin came to
Hollywood many years ago and tried to
have um some films made and struggled
with that can you all talk about your
impressions of his experience here many
years ago and how far have we
come how about that
one
bad you it's after the voting so you
don't have to worry
about um well actually that's a similar
question we hear a lot on during q&as um
how much is have has have things change
in America and it seems like um when we
see the film we feel that Baldwin has
written these words this morning so then
that must mean two things that he's an
incredible
writer uh and also that if those words
that have been written 40 and 50 years
ago is still have such meaning that we
still have a long way to
go
yeah and maybe just to add that uh we
also produced this film from from France
and from Europe and I think we were luy
to to be able to do so because I'm not
sure we would have been able to spend uh
that much time producing this film and
offering Raul and his creative team that
much time to actually made the film if
we were here in America I'm not sure we
would have been able to to raise uh that
much money honey here so that's also to
answer your question yes I appreciate
that well thank you for an incredible an
incredible film really that um I think
transported so many of us to understand
race in the this country in a very
different uh light so I appreciate your
hard work and your incredible
work
yes um so Roger and Julie um Roger is
our fellow Governor so so it's great to
have you up here as well Roger um so my
question to you Roger is prior to doing
life animated you had done a two films
one of which was won an Academy
Award on Africa and then yes and then
you went on to make life animated which
is seems to be a different direction so
how is it or
not how there's a lot of facial
expressions going on I'm just waiting
till you finish so I could okay correct
you so how is it that you decided on
this film yeah um well when I made music
by Prudence um music by Prudence is
about a um a young girl living with a
severe disability who does not have use
of her arms um and does not have legs
and um when I and she lives in Zimbabwe
where disability is considered
witchcraft so when I was making that
film I I learned a lot I and it prepared
me to make this film because I learned
um the importance of Independence um
because um Prudence lived in an
orphanage with kids with severe
disabilities but they Independence gave
them this sort of power this sort of um
Freedom this sort of self-confidence
that just sort of blew me away in a
country with um maab and everything that
was going that they were going through
and so when I um when Ron came to me and
said um you know i' had known Ron for a
while um we we had worked together as
journalists but when he told me the
story of Owen um the first thing I
thought about was that um he this is an
opportunity to tell the story from from
Owen's point of view and this is a
possibility of really spotlighting
Independence and how important that is
for someone who's neurodiverse to own
their story to um be their own person
and uh to and and Owen had and Owen had
this opportunity I had this opportunity
with Owen is to to really have him sort
of speak and represent um people who are
with neurodiverse and who are challenged
in the world and um and so my goal was
always to tell it from his point of view
to really get inside his head and that
was so important and I think I learned
that because I had made a film not so
much about Africa but though it was took
place in Africa but about the power of
Independence for people who have
challenges in this
world
[Applause]
that actually leads me to my next
question for you which is you know in my
experience making documentaries a a huge
challenge is always con figuring out the
best way to connect with people right
but you're working with somebody who is
autistic and where that can be a
challenge so what was your approach with
Owen how did you connect with him how
did you do the interview with him how
did you approach him yeah um well um I
mean I was to be honest I was um
uncomfortable at first cuz I didn't know
how I was going to connect and and I
wanted Owen to tell his story but I
didn't know how I was going to do that
and then um I thought of the idea of the
interon the camera invented by um Errol
Morris and um so um you know Owen who
spent his life looking at a television
screen um connecting to a television
screen if uh what it inter Terron is is
it's a screen and I'm in another room
and Owen is seeing me on a screen so
therefore he can look me right in the
eye he can he can engage with me and
tell the story himself and um and then I
would play Disney Clips on that same
screen and he can engage with those
Disney clips and when we that idea we
came up with that idea it was like a
Eureka moment it was like we um he was
able to own the story he was able to own
the telling of his own story and um and
you were as an audience because he's the
only one who looks the audience directly
he looks directly into the camera
directly into the eye of the audience
you were able to really begin to get
inside his head and slowly be drawn into
his world and his reality and see the
world through his eyes brilliant
brilliant it's awesome
thanks so Julie um this film has had a
wonderful life I premiered at Sundance a
more than a year ago and has had many
screenings I imagine Owen has come to a
number of those screenings can you talk
to us about what his reaction has been
and how that Journey has that been a
journey for him what that process has
been yeah I think it has been a journey
for him actually because I think none
nobody knew what that experience would
be I mean we knew that when Ron and
Cornelia wanted to write the book that
Owen um was really the the driving force
in wanting to have his story told so we
knew that but this is different because
this is him connecting with audiences
and if he was here right now at this
stage he would be like calling on people
he'd be engaging he would be leading it
I mean that's what's really been kind of
wonderful and and that's what happened
with the q&as that I think might have
been surprising even to Ron and Cornelia
and to Walter it was he really
flourished and there were just some
incredible moments with screenings with
him over the last year that I think
Unforgettable for all of us um and also
interactions because there would be um
people who would get up and say you know
I'm on the Spectrum and this is the
first time I feel like my story is being
told and that connection with Owen I
think was really profound and there were
also people saying I've never you know
my my sibling or you know my cousin or
somebody in my life I've never really
known how to talk to them or look at
them and think about them what they're
seeing it was the same kind of a thing
and I think that was incredibly
gratifying for him as well as the rest
of the family but there were some real
doozy of screenings great sure he's he's
a character and he will also say you
know he's looking for a new person new
girlfriend in the Boston Cape cot area
you know he's it's like it's a whole
thing that goes on it's great no filter
I'm glad this film's working for him
um if you know of anyone
yeah um well it's fantastic and I just
love that moment where the father talks
to him for the first time I mean it's
such a great documentary moment so
ronda's voice is as good as Owen almost
well they all do clearly they speak the
whole family
corelia it's
amazing so
Ezra
OJ
um so I'm not sure the film has done as
much for him as it
has um I don't know and he and
presumably he's not here tonight um so
you
know your take and your approach to this
film was so interesting to me because I
think if you know most of us were asked
or decided to do a film on OJ the sort
of obvious way to go about it is is you
know it's a murder case a houd done it
kind of structure it sort of lends
itself to you didn't do that at all like
at all so can you talk to me about what
interested you in this story and kind of
your take on it and why you approached
it the way you did which was brilliant
by the way um because I wasn't
interested in the murder case um and
what interested me was
initially um you know how tired I I
weirdly how tired I was of the
conversation surrounding the murder
trial and so what I thought was um that
conversation was so reductive and even
as we think about it today it still sort
of was thought of in a very binary way
and there were clear antecedence to how
we got to that moment and it was clear
to me that in exploring it this was this
huge story yes about race in America um
but it didn't start um in 1991 when
Rodney King was beaten and the trial
happened a year later and the rids
happened here this was a story that had
um its roots in decades and Decades of
this fraught history in this city that
went back to when um so many black
people migrated here and were confronted
with the reality of what happens here in
Los Angeles as well as what happened in
the Jim Crow South and so there was that
element combined with this incredible
way to use OJ as a character as a lens
through which to talk about our culture
and both from a race standpoint and
identity standpoint but from a celebrity
standpoint and his is a story about so
many things that
I think we all that all affect us that
we all struggle with ambition and
identity and
masculinity um and and frankly that that
sort of quest to fulfill the American
dream which he did and so there was
there was all these elements that when
you started looking at the story
regardless of what was happening during
the trial and what happened whatever um
titilated people when it came to the
question of oh did he do it it was no
this is a story that really is about our
country and every
that we have struggled with um certainly
in the last five decades I really came
very quickly to realize this was the
defining cultural story of our time
and um you know it's it's also somewhat
counterintuitive because your approach
to it um because we were so saturated
with stories of OJ at that time I mean
it was everywhere we were we we all were
living it day in and day out and you
know you told this in seven and a half
hours so talk to me about about that
approach as well and let me tell you
that it was a riveting seven and a half
hours I mean I loved every minute of it
but it's it is counterintuitive at least
for
me um which part that it was long
um I mean look well just you know you
told the story so fully and completely
and broadly which I understand was your
motivation but in did you when you
started this did you think I'm going to
tell this in an hour and a half and then
it got two and a half and then it got
longer and longer or was it I'm telling
an eight hour film and I'm going to fill
up that that time I mean I think uh I
was offered um an opportunity with a
greater canvas it started off as
something was going to be in the four to
five hour range as far as concept and so
I think I wouldn't have done the film if
I had been approached and said if
someone said make a film about OJ make
it whatever you want to makeing about
but it's going to be an hour and a half
long because there would have been an
understanding that it it had to include
the murder and it had to include the
trial and there's nothing you can do in
that time that hasn't already been said
and so for me I was the same as you I
was tired of it and tapped out on it and
so the only reason I even attempted to
take it on the motivation was that I was
being offered this greater canvas in
which I could explore everything that
happened before as well as what happened
after and so in the course of making it
you know as everyone on the stage knows
when you go to make a documentary you
don't know what you're going to be able
to um find once you go out and and start
first researching and then shooting in
terms of who would talk to us this was a
story that you know 20 years later there
are people who had stopped talking about
it hadn't talked about it since the
trial and sort was very clear to me that
it was going to be an uphill battle to
get people to actually engage
um in helping us tell this story and so
with that you know we had the all the
ambition to tell this great story but
you know how to tell a 5 Hour film we
didn't know how to do that any more than
we knew how to make a 50-hour film so we
just went out and started doing it and
then in the course of doing it we
gathered so much material that it grew
and it grew and it grew and luckily we
were working with a company that allowed
us to make the film that it needed to be
and that was a
blessing um
Caroline how hard was it to get people
to be interviewed and you know I think
about people like Mark Mark Ferman who
you know comes across as pretty
potentially racist during the course of
um you know the trial and how did you
all approach somebody like him and how
open were people to to talking to you
all uh well it was challenging
definitely um we had um I mean first we
sort of said about the the two big you
know workflow issues we going to be
gathering all of this archival material
and this film had sort of the opposite
problem of a lot of historical docs that
I've worked on where you're looking and
looking and looking to find things and
this had so much material um archivally
and then obviously the Gathering of
interviews so we sort of divided that
and we had two amazing producers who
worked with us uh tomarrow Rosenberg and
N christic um and uh we sort of said
about those two tasks and yeah the
interviews were were very very
challenging I mean there were some
people who took a year of talking to who
did not agree to participate until you
know a year down the road after we'd
been working um and you know there were
this film more than any other I've I've
said this before where where there was a
lot of you know please don't say no
let's just have coffee please don't say
no just and and there were a lot of
people who said okay we'll give you you
know would meet with Ezra and say okay
I'll give you some background research
but I'm never going to do an interview
and then Ezra would say well okay let's
meet again and maybe we'll you know and
so there was a lot of that um and we had
to do a lot of work um from with people
who had maybe had some terrible media
experiences uh whether it was around the
trial or prior to that so we had to do a
lot of work to get people to trust us
and and I think once they knew we had
this canvas and we were doing this much
deeper longer uh broader look at the
story they they they believed in what
Ezra was you know trying to do and they
saw that what we were doing was
different and and and you know he
prepared so amazingly for you know he
did over 70 interviews um and we really
really wanted to do our homework so that
people knew that we were serious about
the the take you know we were doing well
listen it comes across and it's an
incredibly well- constructed film and
it's as I said riveting and and just
such an important story so thank you for
committing all the time and energy to
make
okay 13th um I'm sorry AA is not here
but you you guys are going to represent
the team beautifully I'm sure so but
tell her we missed her um so Howard
maybe you could start and you know one
of the things that's amazing about 13th
is that you look through this history
over a hundred years in our country and
I feel like I know all of these events
you know slavery and the Civil Rights
Movement and and the police
brutality but you put them all in one
place in a 90 minute or toour feature
and it it says something so profound and
so beautiful and meaningful and hard and
horrible talk to me about that process
Ava um just I'm going to quote her so we
have some sense of her presence in this
room right now but um she she called the
film uh a a virtual tour of racism so
maybe you can talk about that a little
bit well when we started off on the
film you know Ava said to me before we
start anything I need you to read two
books one is called um the new Jim Crow
by Michelle Alexander and the other is
called just Mercy by Brian Stevenson
which if you people out there have not
read that it should be mandatory reading
for everybody in this country
um it you know we started off wanting to
take a macro look at the U American
prison system the industrial Prison
Complex and that led into you know the
history of it and the racial disparities
and and and I think what you know and a
lot of credit goes to Spencer who edited
the film and and Ava I mean they he can
can talk about it more than I but there
we had thousands of hours of footage and
you know at the end of the day you know
they found a way to connect the dots I
think is really what it is and you know
the if you've ever been in therapy and
they talk about the peeling of the onion
and getting you know down to the layers
I think that's what was eventually
successfully you know accomplished is
that we peeled the layers of the onion
back and we found a way to connect the
dots and take you from day one in this
country to where we are now now and you
know I can say on a personal level it
was a horrific journey I mean the things
that I discovered in the the eye
openening experience that I had through
this process of learning the statistics
and the history I mean I was a film
graduate and I I watched Birth of a
Nation 35 years ago in film school but
never looked at it in the way that we
approached it you know in this film so
it's it's you know I hope this becomes
mandatory viewing you know in this
country I can tell you I get a dozen
calls every single day from
universities uh and students around the
country wanting to screen and discuss
the film so it's it's it's it's it's
reach it's got a voice and it's reaching
people well I have to say you know there
is something kind of extraordinary about
watching I am not your negro and OJ and
13th and you know putting those all
together even though they're not
necessarily directly connecting the dots
it tells such a stunning story about
race in this country and you know my
feeling is that all of these films
should be mandatory because they all say
something that is so profound and
important um and interesting
Spencer you know as a as a documentary
filmmaker myself I really appreciate a
good
editor you know a lot happens in the
edit room so talk to me about working
with Ava and what that relationship is
like um and how you guys work together
in that edit
room well um
she's I've been working with her for 10
years now or so and uh she's become one
of my best friends she's you know we're
filmmakers we're collaborators we we
just like to to make films and it's fun
and um
and we take it very serious as well so
you know with this um it was the two of
us um looking
at uh 40 interviews all two to three
hours long thousands of hours of
archival um you know we didn't know
exactly how we wanted to tell this story
um in the beginning but um we you know I
put together a cut that was probably
about 10 hours long and just kind of
string it out see what we have watch it
um and we sort of came out of that and
said you know here's the movie we want
to make and we needed to to unpack it
and move move back to just after the
time um after the Civil War and um you
know it's just it was a collaborative
experience and uh um it wasn't her and
me always in the same room together
working but um you know we we just it
was long process you know I'm trying to
uh remember it all and you know just
like it was horrific experience and
tedious and you know but um we we did it
yeah you did it you did it
so so the red light is blinking telling
me our time is out unfortunately so I
want to just close by saying how
extraordinary each and every one of your
films are and one of you is gonna go
home with that Oscar on Sunday but I
think we all agree that you're all
winners in our book forever and ever and
really so proud of all of you
congratulations thank
you